Since their first film, Toy Story, Disney
Pixar has been amazing audiences and has continued
this for over 20 years but entertainment is
only one factor from the Pixar Universe.
The talented filmmakers at Pixar enjoy sneaking
in hidden secrets and inside jokes in each
one of their films.
You need to live and breathe Pixar films to
know all ten of these because we are not going
to be counting easy secrets like the Pizza
Planet Truck or A113 cameos.
Get prepared to have you mind blown and don’t
forget to subscribe to Screen Rant for more
fun videos like this one.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Secrets
About the Disney Pixar Universe That Will
Blow Your Mind.
The Incredibles in Ratatouille
The film Ratatouille is laced with Easter
Eggs, so much that we all remember when Dug
from UP shows himself but what about The Incredibles
Easter egg?
In one scene Linguini has to find a place
to hide Remy and he looks for the perfect
spot, before deciding in his toque blanche
he has another idea.
That is to place Remy down his pants, once
he pulls open his pants he reveals his boxers
with The Incredibles logo plastered all over
them.
How many of you spotted those boxers because
you almost bought the same pair?
Don’t worry, we won’t judge.
Finding Nemo in Toy Story 3
You’re going to need your pause button for
this one.
When Buzz is making his escape from the Caterpillar
room of the Sunnyside Daycare in Toy Story
3 he whizzes by on string.
If you pause the scene just right you can
see paintings in the background on the window.
Two of these paintings are Dory and Nemo from
Finding Nemo, once you know they are there
it is easy to spot the aquatic characters.
Especially with Nemo’s orange-and-white-striped
colorings.
Luxo Jr. in Wall-E
Planet Earth is covered with so much trash
in 2008’s WALL-E that humans left an adorable
robot by the name WALL-E there to clean it
up.
He has the habit of collecting items he finds
interesting and sharing his spoils with his
cockroach friend.
Once a reconnaissance robot, EVE shows up
he goes from cleaning mode to impressing mode.
In one scene he makes a statue of EVE and
her right arm is made from Luxo, Jr. Pixar’s
favorite desk lamp.
Gastows in Cars 2
It seems that almost every Pixar film has
an Easter Egg with a Cars vehicle in it and
we will be showing you a hard to find one
of those soon.
But what about the Ratatouille nod in Cars
2?
The film takes us on a World Grand Prix tour
with stops in England, Japan and Italy.
One destination the crew travels to is Paris
France and if you don’t blink you might
see Gastows.
Gastows is the vehicular version of Ratatouille’s
Gusteaus Restaurant, maybe the crew stopped
there for a glass of synthetic oil before
the big race.
Monsters, Inc. in Finding Nemo
When we visit the dentist office in Finding
Nemo most people spot the Buzz Lightning toy
on the floor in front of the toy chest.
But that’s not the only toy there, there
is another hidden toy that you can spot if
you turn this dentist office into an optometrist
office.
Focus really hard and look in the toy box,
there is Boo’s teddy bear from Monsters,
Inc.
It’s difficult to make out, but once you
spot it, that’s definitely Boos teddy.
We hope Boo comes back and picks up her teddy
bear.
Luxo Jr. in Toy Story 2
Here is one for you astronomy buffs out there.
Have you ever sat under the night sky and
try to make out a constellation you were taught
about in science class and wonder how those
stars look like a scorpion?
Well, Pixar gave us an easier constellation
to find, when Buzz flies back down to earth
in Toy Story 2 look closely at the stars.
There is Luxo Jr. the famous desk lamp of
the Pixar short film in constellation form.
Let us know if you spot him in the night sky
above your house.
Newt in Brave
Pixar loves to give you sneak peeks in their
current films about upcoming films.
Remember when Boo offered her Nemo doll to
Scully in Monsters, Inc. two years before
Finding Nemo even hit theaters?
In the film Brave, the witch holds a newt
up when concocting a spell to foreshadow the
upcoming film, Newt that Pixar was working
on.
Did you miss this Easter egg or what about
the film Newt?
You probably did because this Newt was shelved
and was never made, but all you true Pixar
fans already knew this.
Right?
Cars in Toy Story 3
Be prepared for not one but three hidden Cars
references in 2010’s Toy Story 3.
In the previous Toy Story film Andy had a
calendar with A Bug’s Life reference on
it but since he’s grown up now we see the
image is now of Snot Rod from Cars.
Then when we head into the Sunnyside Daycare,
one child can be seen sporting a 95 t-shirt
with a lightning bolt design.
That same lightning bolt and red color can
be seen on a wooden car in the background
of the same location.
Did you spot any more Cars references we missed?
Luxo Jr. Ball in Up
The small yellow ball with a blue stripe and
red star was first featured in an early Pixar
short by the name of Luxo, Jr.
Buzz uses it to help fly in the first Toy
Story film and has shown up in a lot of other
Pixar films.
One that people usually miss in in the 2009
film Up because they are paying attention
to the antagonist of Toy Story 3, Lots-o'-Huggin'
Bear.
Look to the right and you can see the Luxo
Jr. ball right in front of the little girl.
Whoever is the manufacturer of this ball is
probably a millionaire now.
The
Incredibles in Finding Nemo
In 2003’s Finding Nemo a boy is seen sitting
near his mother reading a comic book as he
waits to be seen by the dentist.
Nothing looks too peculiar in this scene but
check out that comic book.
It’s a retro design for a golden age, pre-red-suit
Mr. Incredible.
We wonder if Edna Mode had any say in his
outfit, obviously one capped crusader shown
on the comic wasn’t dressed by Edna because
we all know how she feels capes.
There you have it ten secrets about the Disney
Pixar universe that will blow your mind.
Don’t forget to subscribe to Screen Rant
for more fun videos.
Thanks for watching.